The Russians
put the first man on the moon.
That’s steps away from nuclear war.
There’s no going back.
(dramatic music playing)
A three-way race to Mars.
We’re not gonna
come in second place again.
Eli: Today, we take the next step
towards a self-sustaining Mars colony.
♪ "Take Me Out" by Franz Ferdinand ♪
♪
Miles: They’re looking for guys
just like us.
This job on Mars, I could be doing
something that I never even dreamed of.
♪ I say take me out ♪
For the next two years of your lives,
Mars is your new home.
♪ Take me out ♪
Danielle: What’s happened?
Palmer: Something incredible.
This asteroid, it could change everything
for people back home.
Aledia: There’s more oridium
in the asteroid
than has been mined
in the entire history of Earth.
♪ I want you ♪
Dev: We can capture the most valuable
known object in our solar system.
Eli: North Koreans, CIA, KGB,
they’re all wanting a piece of this pie.
Karen: Is it about justice
or filling your pockets?
What are you gonna do
with all that money if you’re dead?
I always thought
I’d go out in a blaze of glory.
♪ To take me out ♪
(yelling)
♪ This could die ♪
Danielle: I’m gonna get that rock
or die trying.
Karen: We are powerless up here.
A millions of miles from my family,
this isn’t what it was supposed to be.
Karen: People are gonna keep getting hurt
while your bank accounts
grow bigger and bigger.
(grunts)
(dramatic music playing)
We’re building a new world for our future.
Ed: You ready to make history?
Always, my friend.
♪ I want you ♪
♪ To take me out ♪